hunter is in tampa florida hey hunter
what's up
hey dave uh thank you guys so much for
taking my call a long time listener
um i am currently on baby step number
one just finished paying off my credit
card
um and now i'm working on student loans
um
very similar situation as your previous
caller so i'm glad he called in before
me
uh but my question for you guys today is
uh i i work in sales and i travel
all around and i you know i use my
personal credit card to expense
um a lot of my traveling and you know
get reimbursed for my company
my question is should i continue using
that card
specifically just for work uh to you
know to build credit and to
to be reimbursed that um and not you
know anything personal
on that card just strictly for business
or should i just put it on my debit card
and pay it off when i get paid
no credit cards on average how much are
you spending a month
um hunter uh for the expenses probably
around uh
in between 14 to 1700 a month
cool so what i would do is i would go
ahead and just put
2 000 extra into your savings account
that you can just cycle through every
single month
so that way you're not you're not
touching your emergency account
and then while you're paying off the
debt you have the two thousand dollars
there that's specifically for work
and you're replacing it every time you
get your reimbursement but i would not
uh going ahead and get a credit card
because the credit card will eventually
be spent on something else
yeah here's the thing here's the thing
i would add a further clarification i
would do it in a separate checking
account i agree yeah
open open a work an account for your
work travel
put two thousand dollars in there before
you go any further before you pay any
extra on your other debts right now
let's get that two thousand dollars in
there once you put it in there
obviously you're going to spend it down
and then the next month they're going to
give you the money back to put it back
so you're
you only have to prime the pump one time
does that make sense
yes sir and then you run a debit card on
that let me tell you what this will
cause you to do it's already kind of
you kind of went just a little bit it's
going to cause you to never use this
card for anything that's not
reimbursable
or with a credit card you go well you
know it's not that big a deal
and it's not reimbursable but and so
your balance you'll get balance creep
on a credit card that you're using for
business expense reimbursement
and you'll look up you got two thousand
dollars owed on it the crap you bought
when you were on the road
because when you're traveling you get
tired you buy stupid butt stuff
can you tell i've done that that's just
you eat too much you eat poorly you spin
poorly road is hard the road is hard
this is the ramsey show